I think there are a substantial number
of scientists who have manipulated data
almost weekly or even daily scientists
who are coming forward and questioning
the original idea that man-made global
warming is what is causing the climate
to change I think it's just the laws of
nature that you have hot years and you
have years of color in case we have
forgotten because we keep hearing that
2014 has been the warmest year on record
you know what this is it's a snowball
that just from outside here so mr.
president catches hmm today the global
warming alarmists are the equivalent of
the flatter thurs you know it used to be
it is accepted scientific wisdom the
earth is flat and this heretic named
Galileo was branded a denier